[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
جنودها
واوكرانيا تخشى تعبئه جديده
مجلس النواب الامريكي يحاول انتخاب رئيسه
والجمهوريون المشتتون يفشون للمره الرابعه
الجنيه المصري في ادنى نقطه في تاريخها
امام الدولار واطلاق شهاده بفائده 25%
للسيطره على التضخم
[موسيقى]
وسيكون لدينا ايضا
كوريا الجنوبيه تهدد جارتها الشماليه
بتعليق الاتفاقات الامنيه وتتعهد ببناء
قوه اكبر من حجم التهديد
[موسيقى]
اربعه ايام على الضربه القاسيه التي
واجهتها اوكرانيا لروسيا في ماكياسكا
لتتجلى في كل يوم فداحه الهجوم الاوكرانيه
يقول ترنسكي ان روسيا تخطط الان لتعبئه
جديده لشن هجوم كبير جديد خصوصا مع زياده
الضغط الداخلي على بوتن واليوم جنه روسيا
مئه وعشره هجمات جويه على اوكرانيا
استهدفت فيها البنيه التحتيه في مدن
مختلفه حسب ما اعلنته وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه ومع التصعيد بين الطرفين وفي
ظل الانتقادات التي يتعرض لها بوتن بسبب
ما حدث في مكيفك لم يعلق الرجل حتى الان
وكان ظهوره الوحيد ليوم بخصوص تدشين قطعه
عسكريه جديده
اود ان اشكر اولا وقبل كل شيء المختصين في
مجمع الصناعات الدفاعيه الذين ابتكروا
وبدوا الانتاج الدخل لهذا السلاح الفريد
كما قلت بالفعل لا يوجد مثيل له في اي
دوله في العالم انا متاكد من ان هذا
السلاح القوي سيسمحوا لروسيا بحمايه نفسها
من التهديدات الخارجيه المحتمله بشكل
موثوق وسيساعدنا في خدمه المصالح الوطنيه
لبلدنا
اذا لضربه تبعات تثقل كاهل القياده
العسكريه الروسيه وتزيد من حرجها الداخليه
اخطاء متكرره وفشل تلو الاخر جعلها في
مرمى الغاضبين من الموالينا لحربها على
جارتها الغربيه اوكرانيا لم تجد وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه نفسها قادره على انتظار
نتائج التحقيق في الضربه القاسيه
فحملت باللوم او حملت اللوم بالحادثه
لجندها الضحايا لكن كيف ذلك السبب في
هواتفهم المحموله التي استخدموها بشكل
مكثف ما سهل من استهدافهم ارتفعت حصيله
قتل الجيش الروسي الى 89 جنديا وفقا متحدث
باسم الوزاره قالوا جانيرو
الذي قال ان عدد رفاقنا القتل ارتفع الى
89 بعد العثور على مزيد من الجثث تحت
الانقاض واضاف ان هناك حاليا لجنه تحقق
لجرائم ملابسات ما حدث لكن من الواضح منذ
الان ان السبب الرئيسي هو ان العسكريين
شغلوا واستخدموا على نطاق واسع هواتفهم
المحموله في منطقه تطالها اسلحه العدو بما
يتعارض مع حضر استعمالها
لكن من الواضح بالفعل ان السبب الرئيسي
لما حدثته والاستخدام المكثف من قبل افراد
الفوج للهواتف المحموله ما جعلهم في
متناول اسلحه العدو وسمح هذا للعدو بتحديد
احداثيات مواقع
الصاروخيه يتم حاليا
ماساويه مماثله في المستقبل نتيجه العداله
تبريد الوزاره
غضبهم على القاده العسكريين وليس الرئيس
الذي لم يعلق حتى الان على الهجوم احد
الغاضبين المراسل الحربي الروسي البارز
والحاصل على وسام الشجاعه من بوتن عام 20
22 ونتحدث هنا عن سيميوم بجوف الذي شك في
الاسباب التي سردتها الوزاره قائلا ان
اوكرانيا حددت القاعده الروسيه بالطائرات
المسيره او المخابرات وليس عن طريق
الهواتف وكتب على تليجرام قائلا ان قصه
الهواتف المحموله ليست مقنعه للغايه نادرا
ما اقول هذا ولكن هذا هو الحال عندما يكون
من الافضل التزام الصمت على الاقل حتى
نهايه التحقيق واشعار الى ان عدد القتلى
سيرتفع بدورهم ارجع مسؤولون بالاستخبارات
البريطانيه الضربه الى الممارسات العسكريه
الروسيه غير المهنيه وكتبت وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه عبر تويتر انه بالنظر الى حجم
الضرر هناك احتمال واقعي ان تكون الذخيره
تم تخزينها بالقرب من اماكن اقامه قوه
الروسيه والتي انفجرت اثناء الضربه ما
تسبب في حدوث انفجارات ثانويه ايضا واضافت
الوزاره ان الجيش الروسي لديه سجل في
تخزين الذخيره بشكل غير امن منذ فتره
طويله قبل الحرب الحاليه لكن هذا الحادث
يصلي الضوء على مدى مساهمه الممارسه غير
المهنيه في ارتفاع معدل الخسائر في روسيا
[موسيقى]
في التاسع والعشرين من سبتمبر الماضي
استعرضنا هنا في العربيه 360 كيف اعترضت
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه مكالمات هاتفيه
لجنود رؤوس تحدث فيها عن ارتكابهم جرائم
حرب وعن مواقعهم وعن فشلهم في دخول
العاصمه كاف حينها تحدثنا كيف عصى الجنود
الروس المنتشرون في الخنادق والحفر وفي
المنازل المحتله في المنطقه المحيطه
ببوتشا وهي ضاحيه غربيه من كيف عصوا
الاوامر من خلال اجراء مكالمات غير مصرح
بها من هواتفهم المحموله الى زوجاتهم
واصدقائهم وكانت ربما سببا انذاك في كشف
مواقعهم وفي فشله هجومهم ومخططهم قال احد
الجنود في تلك المكالمات المسربه ان ثلث
الفوج الذي يخدم في مبيد بينما افاد جنود
من الفوز
331 المحمول جوا بان الكتيبه الثانيه
باكملها المكونه من 600 جنديه قد تم
القضاء عليها الاخطاء ذاتها تتكرر ولم
يتعلم القدر رؤوس والجنود لم يتعلموا اي
درس من الماضي على ما يبدو وهذا امر
مستغرب من الجميع في الواقع لنستذكر
واياكم احدى هذه المكالمات
غير رئيس روسي قائد الحرب في اوكرانيا
ثلاث مرات منذ بدئها في فبراير من العام
الماضي تغير الاشخاص لكن الاخطاء مستمره
وتتكرر وبطريقه مستعجنه يقول خبير امني
امريكي لصحيفه وسط جورنال ان العقليه
السوفياتيه لا تزال تحكم الجيش الروسي
المركزي المطلقه وتراجع مراكز القياده
واضافه الى بعدها عن مسرح العمليات بسبب
الخوف من الضربات الاوكرانيه كل ذلك اسهما
بخلق العديد العديد من المشكلات اللوجستيه
قذف الى ذلك تخزين الاسلحه الخاطئ كما
ذكرنا ضربه مكيه في كالمحرجه قد تقود الى
انتقام روسي كبير وهو محذر منه الرئيس
شخصيا قائلا ان روسيا سته شنه هجوما كبيرا
خصوصا مع اطلاق جماعه قوميه غير معروفه
تدعم ارامل الجنود الروس دعوات لبوتن تطلب
منه اعلان تعبئه واسعه لملايين الروس
واغلاق الحدود لضمان تحقيق النصر في
اوكرانيا
هذا العام بمعالجه اكثر ما تحتاجه
اوكرانيا في الوقت الحالي قبل التعبئه
التي تعدها الدوله الارهابيه وهذا هو
بالضبط الوقت الذي يتعين علينا فيه مع
شركائنا تعزيز دفاعتنا ليس لدينا ادنى شك
في ان اسياد روسيه الحاليين سوف يرمون كل
ما تبقى لديهم لمحاوله قلب الوضع بالحرب
وعلى الاقل تاخير هزيمتهم
معنى من ناموسكو مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد
الرسل
العربيه كذلك اهلا بك عبد الجواد يبدو انك
يعني تحت الثلوج التي تنهمر في العاصمه
الروسيه
ويعني لن اطيل عليك لاسالك عن الاجواء
الاضافيه التي لا تزال تتردد حول تداعيات
ما حصل في مكه كيف تتعامل مختلف الشرائح
الروسيه الرسميه وغير الرسميه مع هذا
الموضوع
مساء الخير طاهر لك وللجميع الحذيفه صحيح
ما تقول العديد من شرائح المجتمع الروسي
يظهر الانزعاج لديها ان كان لدى حديث
الناس او في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي حول
ما حدث عشيه راس السنه الجديده
وخروج العشرات بين قتله او جرحى من صفوف
الجيش الروسي طبعا وهؤلاء الاشخاص لهم وضع
خاص باعتبار لا يملكون تلك الخبره الطويله
في الاعمال القتاليه باعتبارهم تم دعوتهم
للتعبئه خلال الفتره الاخيره الماضيه طبعا
طاهر العديد من الشخصيات الرسميه في روسيا
تحدثت عن سوء التقديرات وسوء القياده نوعا
ما في تلك المنطقه حتى هذه اللحظه الجميع
ينتظر بفارغ الصبر عمليه التحقيقات وزاره
الدفاع كما تحدثت ستقوم بمحاس المسؤول عن
هذا الموضوع كما سمتها هي ماساه كبيره من
العيار الثقيل ضربت لكريملين عشيه راس
السنه كما ذكرت لذلك طبعا هو انزعاج كبير
لدى كافه الناس لما حصل هي خسائر كبيره
الجميع يتحدث عن ان الاعداد قد تكون اكبر
قد تصبح اكبر باعتبار ان اعداد الجرحى هي
كبيره وما زال العمل والبحث تحت الانقاد
جاريا
من ضربه كبيره
كما سمتها هل هناك ما يؤشر روسيا على
امكانيه حدوث ذلك همم اضافه الى امكانيه
ان تستمع القياده الروسيه الى دعوات بعض
المتشددين بخصوص تعبئه مليونيه واقف
للحدود
يعني تعبئه مليونيه تحدثت عنها اليوم او
تحدث عنها اليوم مجلس الدمى والحديث طبعا
كان على لسان نائم يعني نائب مسؤول الدفاع
لدى مجلس الشعب الروسي ومجلس الدمى حيث
قال ان التعبئه القادمه لن تكون يعني خلال
النصف عام القادم والمده طبعا المتوقع هي
بعد سته اشهر من الان وهذا الشيء مرتبط
بسير العمليه العسكريه لكن طبعا كما ملاحظ
وكما يدور الحديث لدى الدائره العسكريه في
البلاد بان ضربات موسكو اليوم اصبحت موجعه
واصبح بيان وزاره الدفاع يتحدث عن خسائر
اكبر العادات اصبح حتى تقدر بالمئات يعني
خلال اليوم الماضي 500 شخص بين قتيل وجريح
العدل من المناطق تم ضربها بصواريخ روسيه
او بمسيرات بالاضافه الى اسقاط طائرات
واحده ميك والثانيه سو تابعه للقوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه وهذه الاعداد هي تاتي
خطوه كخطوه الرد من قبل موسكو بدء من
الاول من الشهر حتى اليوم وهو الرابع
والاعداد اصبحت تزيد عن 1500 شخص بين قتيل
وجريح حسب روايه موسقات ااا اعود تبقى
معنا انتقل الى حذيفه عادل الان مراسلنا
من كياب حيث اعتقد انه البروده ايضا شديده
جدا كما هو واضح همم رغم يعني سخونه همم
ما يجري على الارض والمقاس التي تحدث على
الارض
حذيفه الشق الجانب الاوكراني شرائح
المختلفه ايضا على الاصعده الرسميه وغير
الرسميه ما الذي تقوله بالشان وتاكده بشان
هذه العمليه واي احتياطيات بعد تحذير
الرئيس ذا لانسكي من ضرب بانتقاميه
نعم تحياتي طاهر لك والي الزميل لعبد
الجواد في الحقيقه ال ال الاستخبارات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه تحدثت حول هذا
الموضوع في اكثر من مناسبه بدانا في رئيس
الاستخبارات في اليومين الماضيين تحدث
بالاستفاضه عن وضع الجيش الروسي وتوقعاته
للوضع في الايام القادمه خاصه في ما يخص
الهجمات الانتقاميه المتوقعه من قبل
الاتحاد الروسي والتي حذر منها الرئيس
وقال ان الاتحاد الروسيه تصيد المناسبات
الدينيه والاعياد وطبعا تعلم ان في
السابعه من هذا الشهر هنالك مناسبه او عيد
وفي هذا اليوم تحديدا تتوقع كيف ان يكون
هنالك هجمه واسعه ان نطاق ولكن الرئيس
الاستخبارات قال بشكل واضح ان الصفقه
الاخيره للمسيرات الايرانيه التي ابرمها
الاتحاد الروسي
250 طائره مسيره تم استخدام نصفها حتى
الان لذلك الاتحاد الروسي غير قادر على
اطلاق هجمات واسعه النطاق سوف يجزئ هذه
الكميه متبقيه لو حتى يستطيع الحصول على
صفقه جديده والحصول على مسيرات جديده لذلك
الهجمات قد تكون بارقام قليله حوالي 30
مسيره في اليوم او اقل من ذلك ايضا عن
الصواريخ التي يطلقها الاتحاد الروسي
يحتاج الى زمن طويل لاعاده تصنيع مثل هذه
الصواريخ هو ايضا الان يبحث عن صفقات
للصواريخ يحاول ان الحصول على صواريخ من
الشركاء لذلك ليس لدى الاتحاد الروسي الان
القدره على شان هجوم واسعا نطاق وانما سوف
يقوم بهذه الهجمات الانتقاميه في مناسبات
معينه وبعينها ايضا همم الجانب الاوكرانيا
يتحدث عن ان همم الاتحاد الروسي الذي
يحارب في ارض المعركه لن يقاتل ولن ينفذ
هجماته في مراكز همم تواجد الجنود والقوات
في خط النار وانما سوف يقاتل المدني
الرئيس ابنكي وايضا قال قائد الجيش انه
يقاتل المدنيين ويطلق صواريخه في المناطق
المهوله يعني
في الفتره الاخيره في تحديدا في خط النار
الان الجيش الروسي يحاول ان يفرز سيطرته
على ثلاثه مناطق رئيسيه في منطقه باخوه
وذلك للتعويض كما قال قائد الجيش العام
الخسائر الكبيره والتي بلغت حتى الان في
اليوم حوالي 720 جنديا كما افاد اليوم
رئيس الاستخبارات العسكريه طاهر شكرا
جزيلا لك على كل هذه المعلومات حذيفه هذه
المراسل العربيه امريكيات عبد المجيد
مراسل العربيه من موسكو تحياتي اليكما
[موسيقى]
يتجه مجلس النواب الامريكي الى فشل للمره
الخامسه في اختياري رئيسا له ولم يتمكن
المرشح الاقوى النائب عن ولايه كاليفورنيا
كان المقارثي من نيلي دعم الاغلبيه في
مجلس النواب الذي سيطر عليه الديمقراطيون
بعد الانتخابات الذي سيطر عليه الجمهوريون
بعد الانتخابات النصفيه في نوفمبر فيما لا
يزال الديمقراطيون يستيرون على مجلس
الشيوخ وبعد جلسه رابعه فشلت قبل همم
ايضا الخامسه يبدو انها فشلت تجهلها مجلس
النواب الى جلسه خامسه ويبدو اذا انها لن
تكون افضل حظا بانتظار الجلسات اللاحقه
متابع هذه الصور على الهواء اذا مشاهدينا
الكرام للجلسه الخامسه التي يبدو انها
تتجه للفشل في اختيار رئيس لمجلس النواب
من الجمهوريين المشتتين وال متنازعين بين
بعضهم البعض خلفا لنانسيبي لوسي رئيسه
مجلس النواب عن الحزم الديمقراطي رئيسه
الاغلبيه الديمقراطيه همم
ايام سيطرت الديمقراطيين على المجلس
وبانتظار الجلسات المقبله لنرى اذا كانت
كل الدعوات بما فيها دعوه الرئيس السابق
ترامب لبعض الجمهوريين بتاييد ترشيح مكان
كارثه همم سنرى اذا كان ذلك يعني ينفع امل
الواضح بانه الكل يحاول ان يمرر شروطه قبل
همم تمرير تعيين او اختيار
ونحن نتابع هذه الصور اذا معنا من واشنطن
مراسل العربيه حسين الطاوض اهلا بك معنا
حسين اذا يبدو ان الجلسه الخامسه ايضا
اتجهت الى الفشل بانتظار الجلسات الاخرى
على الاقل اعتقد واحده لا تزال اليوم هل
يمكن ان تدلل العقبات التي منعت ااا
انتخاب رئيس مجلس النواب في الجلسه
السادسه هل من معلومات جديده
تحيه لك طاهر يبدو انه سيكون هناك جلسه
سادسه لان الجلسه الخامسه الان همم المرشح
الجمهور الاخر دونالدز حصل حتى الان على
11 صوتا كما ارى هنا همم هذا يعني ان هناك
جوله السادسه قد تكون اخيرا اليوم همم
طبعا همم مكارثي حاول جاهدا خلال منذ
البارحه والى اليوم ان يحصل على او يؤمن
العدد الكافي همم لحصوله على منصب رئيس
مجلس النواب وهو 218 وكما انه روج الفكره
تخفيض عدد ال- ال- المطلوب همم لفوزه بهذا
المصري من 218 الى الاقل الى 200 و13 ان
يلتزم بعض الجمهوريين الصمت او يصوت بحاضر
عند اذن عتمه الاصوات تنخفض على حسب طبعا
عدد الذين يمتنعون عن التصويت لكن حتى هذا
لم يحدث همم بعد ذلك تعهد اكثر من مره
بانه سيستمر حتى النهايه في همم في هذه
الحمله حتى يفوز بمنصب اا رئيس مجلس
النواب طبعا همم دعوات التي اطلقها الرئيس
السابق دون ترامب وحتى نائبه مايك بيرس
نايبوبه السابق لم تلقى صدا كما نرى الان
لدى هؤلاء الجمهوريين من اليمين الذي يوصل
باليمين المتطرف في الحزب الجمهوري هناك
الاسباب التي يبدونها حسين لماذا
يومانعون وهم من الجمهوريين ولكن خطهم
اكثر تشددا همم لماذا يماني همم انتخاب
همم مقارتي
طاهر هم يعتبرون ان ماكرتي ااا معتدلا هو
هو ايضا يتهمونه ورغم انه مقرب من ضمن
ترامب ودونالد ترامب يدعمه يعتبرون ان
مارتي لم يظهر الولاء الكافي لدونالد
ترامب ولم يدافع عنه بشكل كافر خلال
تحقيقات السادس من يناير هذه واحده هناك
همم عندهم مطالب اخرى يقولونها لاصلاح
مجلس النواب الاصلاح الكونغرس هم مثلا
طالبوا بان همم كنا لديهم اليه لبدا همم
همم او اطلاق العمليه لعزل رئيس مجلس
النواب من خلال التصويت لخمسه نواب
جمهوريين بدل نصف النواب الجمهوريين همم
للامانه همم
مكارتي اعطاهم ذلك تنازل في هذه المساله
ولكنه رفض مثلا التنازل همم في موضوع اخر
همم هناك العديد من الامور هم يختلفون مع
مكارثي عليها يطالبونه بالكثير من كره قدم
تنازلات مؤخرا ولكنه لا يستطيع الان وفق
مراقبين ان يقدم المزيد لانه اذا قدم لهم
المزيد سيبتعد عنه المعتدلون في مجلس
النواب وعندها في مشكله اخرى مهمه
ااا تحدث في طبعا الاغلبيه في الواقع
مكارتي لديه الاغلبيه في مجلس النواب عن
الجمهوريين من يقفون نظرهم اقليه من
الجمهوريين لكنها اقليه كافيه لتمنعه حتى
الان كما راينا من الحصول على هذا او
الفوز بهذا المنصب منصب رئاسه مجلس النواب
ولكن ما يدور الان همم في الوقت مجلس
النواب هو الحديث عن موضوع ان يكون هناك
مرشح توافقي بين الجمهوريين والديمقراطين
يكون جمهوري ولكن حتى الان الديمقراطيون
يقول انهم لن يتدخل لانقاذ الجمهوريين
يعتبرون ان هذا مازق للجمهوريين عليه من
يحل المشكله يعني
ايضا حديث عن امكانيه ان يتخلى بكار في عن
هذا الهدف لصالح سيف
لكن هو ايضا من المقربين اللي مقارنه
والبعض من المعتديين يقولون ما الفرق بين
بين همم بكار في همم واسكارس هما من نفس
المدرسه هما لا ف يا ماما سيواجهان نفس
المشكله مع اليمين المتشدد في الحسبه
الجمهوري شكرا جزيلا لك حسين طوط مراسل
العربيه من واشنطن على كل هذه المعلومات
ولنا عوده اليك والى مراسلين عندما نتابع
الجلسه السادسه المفترضه ايضا لانتخاب
رئيس لمجلس النواب الامريكي بعد على اثر
الفشل الذي حصل في خمس جلسات متتاليه همم
شكرا لك حسين وان نتابع واياكم من الاخبار
العاجله الوارده عن وزير الدفاع اسرائيل
الذي يقول لنظيره الامريكي ملتزمون بفعل
كل شيء لمنع ايران من امتلاكي سلاح
النوويه تخبط شديد للجمهوريين بعد فشلهم
في تحقيق موجه حمراء في انتخابات نوفمبر
كما ارادوا على الاقل والان ورغم فوزهم
بمجلس النواب لا يستطيعون انتخاب رئيس
لمجلس النواب ترامب جمهوريين اليوم الى
التصويت لما كارثه اذن وهو لم يكن موقف
ترامب امس او في ايام لهود الماضيه حينما
احجم عن دعمه
علانيه كما كان يقول حسين ويعتبر معتدلا
ولا يرى ترامب مع مساعدين وحلفاء بانه
دعموا في تحقيقات احداث يناير في الكابل
ترامب سحب من مكارثي الدعم بحجه انه لا
يقف خلف الجيولوجيته بشكل كامل وبالتالي
اغضب اعضاء جمهوريين تعد اصواتهم حاسمه
لحسم منصب رئيس مجلس النواب كسب البعض
وخسر البعض الاخر امس تجنب ترامب الرد على
سؤال من شبكه ام بي سي نيوز حول دعمه
لمقارتي ولم يرد على السؤال بشكل مباشر
ليقول سنرى ما سيحدث ويضيف ترامب بشكل
النصي العديد من النواب ارادوا الحصول على
دعم لقد اتصل بالجميع هذا كل ما يمكنني
قوله سنرى كذب كيف سينتهي هذا الامر انتهى
الامر اليوم باعلان ترامب انه يدعم مكه
لكن يظل عدد من حلفاء الرئيس السابق يرون
المرشح لرئيس مجلس النواب
بمظهر اللين مع الديمقراطيه
[موسيقى]
امريكي وسالتهم عن ما اذا كانت كونغرس
يقوم بعمل جيد وعما اذا كانوا يحبون
الطريقه التي تدار بها الامور في واشنطن
من المحتمل ان تسمع رفضهم للطريقه التي
تدار بها الامور بشكل كبير نريد تغيير
الطريقه التي تتم بها الامور هنا
لا يستحق ان يكون في منصب رئيس مجلس
النواب وصوت الى جانبي 19 جمهوريه اخرين
بالامس للنائب من ولايه اوهايو جيم جوردن
للمجلس رغم ان ترامب في دعمه الاخير قال
انه سيقوم بعمل رائع حينما يصبح رئيس ايسا
وعلى الجمهوريين متابعه ذلك
ابن خالتي
لكنه رفضها سعينا للتصويت في الربع الاول
من الكونغرس 118 على حدود الفتره لقد رفض
اردنا ميزانيه من لجنه الدراسه الجمهوريه
في الربع الاول رفض ردنا خطه الحدود التي
وضعها وفد تكساس على الارض لقد رفض نحن
نعاني من ازمه ثقه مع ذكرته
قال ان على الجمهوريين عدم تحويل الانتصار
الكبير في الانتخابات الى هزيمه هائله لكن
يبدو ان الدعم وصل متاخرا يقول انه تمت
الكثير من المحادثات بعد فشل المقارتي في
الحصول على التصويت وقد حان الوقت الان
لجميع الاعضاء الجمهوريين بان يصوت لصالح
كارثي وانهاء هذا الامر ولم يترك ترامب
غرينته السياسيه
دون انتقاد في رسالته واكد ان التصويت
لمكارسي يعني سال نانسي بيلوسي الى منزلها
في كاليفورنيا وهي مكسوره ويتمتع
الجمهوريون باغلبيه بسيطه في مجلس النواب
ب22 مقعدا مقابل 212 مقعدا وقد تسبب
انشقاقه النواب الجمهوريين في احراج للحزب
[موسيقى]
احدى العثرات امام فوز مكارثي هي اعتقاد
البعض في الجناح اليمني للحسبه ان مطار في
لا يدين بالولاء بدرجه كافيه لترامب الذي
سيخوض سباق البيت الابيض مجددا ياتي ذلك
رغم ان مقار في مثلا رفض ان يمتل امام
اللجنه التي تحقق في احداث اقتحام الكابتل
عام 2021 في اشاره دعم واضحه لترامب كما
وعدت الاعضاء الجمهوريين اليمنيين باجراء
تحقيقات تطلب ايضا وعائلته واداراته اضافه
الى مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي ووكاله
الاستخبارات المركزيه وهو الامر الذي يجعل
مكار في يسير على خيط رفيعه حيث قد يراه
الوسطيون في الحزب الجمهوريه انه يرضى كل
اليمين ما يعني احتمال نايهم عنه
[موسيقى]
نحن بكون معكم في العربيه 360 لمتابع ما
لدينا بعد الفصل تبقى معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد سجل سعر صرف الجنيه
المصري تراجع عن قويا جديدا امام الدولار
حيث قيمه البنوك الدولار الواحد عنده 26
جنيه و 45 قرشا ياتي هذا تراجع نزولا من
مستوى
24.7 للدولار في تعاملات امس وتعد هذه
اكبر خساره يوميه للجنيه منذ ان سمح البنك
المركزي بل انخفاضه بنسبه 14 ونصف بالمئه
في السابع والعشرين من اكتوبر تشرين الاول
الماضي وجاء الهبوط بعد قرار بنك مصر
والبنك الاهلي المصري صباح اليوم طرحها
شهادات لمده عام بالعمله المحليه بفائده
تصل الى 25%
[موسيقى]
البنك الاهلي وابنك مصر وهما مصر فان
مملوكا للدوله تحرك لاصدار شهادات استثمار
مدتها سنه بفائده 25% الهدف هو اغراؤه
حائز الدولار بتحويل ما لديه للجنيه
للاستفاده من هذا العائد فهل سيقبل البعض
عليها توفير للادرار لغز
ويجيب شهادات من اللي هي الجديده دين
العائد بتاعها عالي همم لان الدولار اكيد
اسعاره هتبقى متوازنه في السوق في المرحله
المقبله بعد اصدار هذه الشهاده
بانه بدايه التعويم الثالث لهذا العام
ووصفه اخرون انه دليل على مرونه سعر الصرف
في التماهي مع العرض والطلب
هذا تراجع في قيمه الجنيه امام الدولار
دعا بعض للتشكيك في مدى اقبال المصريين
على هذه الودائع تحرك اسعار الصرف او
انخفاض الجنيه كان مقيمه اكبر بكثير من
الشهادات الطرحه يعني احنا اعلى شهاده
تقريبا طرحت كانت 18% مازال هو اللي اتجه
للشهادات هو برده ما قدرش ان هو يحافظ على
ثروته او
الممتلكات بتاعته مقاومه الدولار
بشانها ان يكذب المصريين للتخلي عن
الدولار مقابل عائد مادي مجزي ولكن في نفس
الوقت هذه الفائده المرتفعه تقول الكثير
عن الغلاء المتوقع في خادم الايام تبين
توقعته الشارع حول معدلات التضخم في
الفتره القادمه
مش مستنيها شهداء المصريين هيحطوا مبالغ
كبيره هيحطوا مبالغ كبيره جدا في البنوك
فالنقد اللي معاهم في يديهم هيقل فاعتقم
دي هت كنترول شويه في اسعار السلع يعني
الحكومه المصريه وكانت قد اجلت تحريك
اسعار المحروقات والكهرباء كنوع من
التخفيف على المواطنين وبالتالي فهناك
ترقب للاجتماع القادم للجنه المسؤوله عن
تحديد سعر الوقود لان هذا ايضا يشكل عاملا
هاما في تحديد تكلفه السلعه ومن ثم في
تحديد اسعارها تامر ناصر العربيه القاهره
معنى من القاهره الان مراسله العربيه
لشؤون الاقتصاديه فهيمه زايد اهلا بك معنا
فهيمه اضافه الى المعلومات والشروحات التي
قدمها تامر نصرت في تقريره اريد ان تفسر
لنا اكثر الفرق بين التعويم وسعر الصرف
المرن هل نحن امام تعويم ولو كان مضبوطا
اذا صح التعبير يمكن ان تدققي لنا في
المصطلح همم وامس سعر صرف مرن فقط
في الواقع همم احنا مرينا في عده همم مرات
من التعويض يعني اول تعويم كان في عام
2016 همم وبعدها العام الماضي كان هناك
تعويمين الاول في همم مارس والثاني في همم
اكتوبر مع اتمام اتفاق صندوق النقد ومنظر
للتفاق مع صندوق النقد في السابع والعشرين
من اكتوبر تم الاتفاق على فكره مرور سعر
الصرف ان يكون سعر الصرف متحرك وفقا للقوى
العارضه هو منذ ذلك الوقت والبنك المركزي
يتحدث عن هذه المرونه وان هناك مرونه في
سعر الصرف وبالتالي لم يتم همم ذكر همم
فكره التعويمه الثالث همم او التعويمه
الاول للعام الحالي همم مره اخرى انما
الحديث كله عن مرونه اكبر لسعر الصرف وفقا
للاتفاق الذي تم معه صندوق النقد الدولي
همم
جميل جدا الان عندما همم يتم همم اقرار
طرح شهادات بالعمله المحليه همم من قبل
البنك المركزي والبنك مصر والبنك الاهلي
المصري الى اي مدى باعتقادك يمكن فعلا ان
يجذب ذلك الاموال المصريه خاصه في ظل حاله
يعني خوف تصيب عاده الناس عندما يعني تبدا
هذه الامور بالحصول والتكرار
همم في 21 مارس عندما تم التعويض من الاول
العام الماضي همم تم اصدار شهادات همم
ادخار بعائد الثمانيه 10% ووقتها لم
يستغرق الامر اكثر من شهرين حتى تجمع يجمع
البيت بنك مصر والاهلي نحو 750 مليار جنيه
عندما تكررت
القضيه مره اخرى في التعويمه الثاني في
السابع والعشرين من اكتوبر تم اصدار
شهادات همم
بعض البنوك المصريه الحكوميه بنحو 17:15%
هذه الشهادات لم تلقى قبولا كبيره وذلك في
ضوء همم النشاط الكبير الذي شهده همم
السوق الموازي والفعل الذي وصل الى تقريبا
سته وثلاثون همم جنيها للدولار هذا كله
دفع المواطنين الى همم الاحتفاظ بالدولار
بشكل افضل همم على بس انا العائد الشهاده
لن يجلب للمواطن الذي يحمل الدولار مكسب
كمكسب الدولار نفسه وتحرك الجنيه وايضا مع
القرار اللي طلع من صندوق النقد في اا
ديسمبر الماضي بالموافقه على القرض لمصر
ذكر فيه ايضا مرونه سعر الصرف واكد عليها
فهذا اعطى للمواطنين همم فكره ان هناك ما
زال همم فرصه لتحرك سعر صرف صوره اكبر
وانخفاض اكثر للجنيه ولذلك تم الاحتفاظ
بالدولار بل بالعكس كان هناك اقبال كبير
جدا على شراء الذهب او الاحتفاظ بالدولار
ولذلك شاهدنا مضاربات كبيره جدا على اسعار
الذهب وايضا وضربات كبيره في السوق
الوضع على ما هو عليه بعد هذا التراجع
القوي الجديد في سعر صرف الجنيه همم ماذا
سيتبقى من خيارات امام الحكومه لكي تحاول
انقاذ الوضع مع همم
عايشه وزياده الاسعار السلعه
اا طاهر همم من المرتقب يعني قرار تحريك
سعر الصرف مره اخرى وخفض الجنيه مره اخرى
كان متوقعا في ضوء ترقب مصر
لحزمه المساعدات التي ذكرها ال- اا صندوق
النقد الدولي من الشركاء الدوليين وايضا
الشركاء الخليجيين دول الخليج وهي بقيمه
14 مليار دولار هذه الحزمه اللي انت تكون
خاصه للاستثمارات الخليج لن تكون مساعدات
او ودائع ولكن ستكون عباره عن استثمارات
وشراء اصول مصريه كان من المرتقب انخفاض
الجميع حتى يمكن لهذه الصفقات انت تتم فلا
يمكن ان تتم هذه الصفقات وهناك فجوه كبيره
جدا بين السكر رسمي وغير الرسمي فبالتالي
همم في حاله حدوث اتمام هذه الصفقات همم
حصول مصر على ارادات دولاريه يمكن ان يحدث
تلاقي انا العرض والطلب و اا يخف الضغط اا
قليلا على الطلب على العمله وبالتالي يمكن
ان يحدث التوازن ويبدا كما حدث في عام
2016 عندما همم قفز ال- الدولار بصوره
كبيره ثم تراجع بعد ذلك قليلا شكرا جزيلا
على هذه الشروحات الوافيه مراسله العربيه
لشؤون الاقتصاديه فهيمه زايد من القاهره
تحيه اليك
[موسيقى]
الازمه التي اثارها وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي
المسجد الاقصى لا تزال محطه الاهتمام حيث
امتد الامر لاجنده الوزراء المتشددين
بحكومه الجديده
ان هذا التشدد قد يوحد صفوف الفلسطينيين
ويعيدوا الاهتمام بالقضيه الفلسطينيه
في الوقت الذي ساعات فيه اسرائيل في
السنوات الاخيره الى تهميش القضيه
الفلسطينيه واخراجها من دائره الاهتمام
العالمي والاعلامي وترويج نظريه النحل
صراع العربي الاسرائيلي سيحل ذلك
الفلسطيني الى العكس فان سيطره اجنده
وزراء حكومه نتنياهو اليمنيين قد تؤتي
نتائج عكسيه فاقتحام بن جرير الاقصى مثلا
قبل بتسونامي من ردود الفعل العربيه
والدوليه واوصل ملف الانتهاكات في الاقصى
والقدس الى مجلس الامن من خلال طلب عربي
تمديد الدولي والعربي بزياره بنجير للحرم
القدسي واعتزام الائتلاف تعديل قانون
المستوطنات كل هذا وغيره يدل على ان
الموضوع الفلسطيني يفرض نفسه وبالقوه على
نتنهام
يضرب مجددا حيث اعلن انه سيحرم قريبا
الاسرى الفلسطينيين من حقوق وامتيازات الى
جانب اطلاق اليد في البناء الاستيطاني ما
قد يقابل باضراب جماعي عن الطعام وانفجار
الميدانيه على الارض ويوحد الفلسطينيين
المنقسمين ضد اسرائيل وقد ينقلب السحر على
الساحر وتلف الحكومه اليمنيه الاسرائيليه
نفسها من خلال ممارساتها وتصعيدها على
الارض تجبر العالم والاقليم على الطاعات
مع المساله الفلسطينيه بوثيره متسارعه على
حساب الاولويه الاسرائيليه التي تقول انها
ايران
يعني هذه الحكومه على التطرفها وعلى سوءها
اعتقد انه يمكن فعلا ان تكون فرصه لدى
الشعب الفلسطيني هذه الحكومه منقسم حولها
الشارع الاسرائيلي لا يوجد اجماع حولها
منبوذه من حلفاء مهمين لاسرائيل خاصه في
الغرب الاداره الامريكيه واوروبا وايضا هي
يعني تغلق كل الافق امام الفلسطينيين
وبالتالي تدفع باتجاه توحيدهم التزاوج بين
يمين متشدد يغازل قاعدته الجماهيريه
ونتنياهو المضطر لتنفيذ جندات مودريتش
لمساعدته تشريعان على الافلات من قبضه في
قضايا الفساد يفسر انها اول حكومه من اصل
ست حكومات لا يتحالى فيها نتنياهو مع
احزاب وسطيه او يساريه اكثر قبولا في
العالم زياد حلبي العربيه الاراضي
الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
مجددا الى جلسه مجلس النواب الامريكيه
الذي يفشل للمره الخامسه على ما يبدو
بانتخابي رئيسا لا هو كبن مكارثي لا يزال
غير قادر على تحصيل الاصوات العشرين التي
هو بحاجه اليها لكي يمرر انتخابه في هذا
المجلس لرئاسه على اثر فوز الجمهوريين في
اغلبيات مجلس النواب همم هناك انقسام كبير
بين اعضاء مجلس النواب الجمهوريين رغم
دعوه ترامب نفسه لتاييد مكارتي الا ان بعض
مؤيدين ترامب حتى الان لم يقتنعوا
بتاييد مكارثي يبدو انه يريدون ان يضعوا
المزيد من الضغوط عليها كي يتماشى مع
مطالبهم وقد حصلت وتحصل المفاوضات
واتصالات اا حثيثه في هذا المجال ل يعني
تلبيه رغباتهم وطلباتهم وهم يعتبرون من
المتشددين بدون شك يعيبون عليها انه معتدل
بالنسبه اليهم وانه لم يتخذ قرارات حاسمه
ولم يقف بشكل كافن مع ترامب في التحقيق
باحداث الكابيتول همم هذا منصب مهم جدا في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه همم المنتخب
سيكون ثالث اهم شخصيه في المشهد السياسي
الامريكي بعد طبعا الرئيس ونائب الرئيس
نائب الرئيس في هذه الحاله هذه المره
نانسي كنا نراها قبل قليل ستغادر رئاسه
مجلس النواب على اثر
يعنيتها لفتره طويله همم له في فترات
الاغلبيه الديمقراطيه ولكن الان اختلف
المشهد سنقينا
نتابع من تجارب كوريا الشماليه الصاروخيه
واختراق طيرانها المسير لاجواء الشقيقه
اللدوده كوريا الجنوبيه ما اثار المخاوف
في شرق اسيا المتجه نحو مزيدا من التوتر
التنين والصيني الجامح وحليفه في
بيونغيانغ محطه انظار العالم اخترق
الطائرات مسيره تابعه لكوريا
مؤخرا خرق لم يتحرك الجيش الكوري الجنوبي
لمواجهته كما يجب على ما يبدو بناء على
اتفاق امني وقع عام 2018 الاتفاق المذكوره
وقع على هامشي قمه بين الزعيم الكوري
الشمالي ورئيس كوريا الجنوبيه حينها
مونجيئين يدعو الى وقفه كل التصرفات
الغذائيه واقامه منطقه حضر طيران على
الحدود اضافه الى ازاله الالغام الارضيه
ومواقع حرس الحدود داخل المنطقه منزوعات
السلاح شديده التحصين اتفاقه ان انتقده
الرئيس الجديد لكوريا
يونج
الطائرات الكوريه الشماليه بدون طيار
مجالنا الجوي هو حادث لا يطاق كثير من
الناس كانوا قلقين يجب ان نضع كوريا
الشماليه تعلم ان الاستفزازات تقابل دائما
بعواقب وخيمه يجب ان نراجع نظام الاستجابه
الشامل لدينا ضد جميع الاجسام الطائره
التي تنتهي كوما جانا الجوي وان نحسن على
الفورعدنك
الرئيس
هدد بتعليق الاتفاق العسكري انف الذكر في
حال اخترقت بيوم بيونجا المجال الجويه
لبلاده مجددا ولم
يكتفيول بتهديده بل دعى جيش بلاده الى
بنائه قدره رد ساحقه تتجاوزه حدود التناسب
منتقدا بالوقت نفسه طريقه التعامل الجيش
مع حادثه الطائرات المسيره
سواء كانت لديهم اسلحه نوويه او اي نوع من
اسلحه دمار الشامل يجب ان نرسل رساله
واضحه الى الاشخاص الذين يقومون
بالاستفزازات بشكل متكرر ويجب الا نخاف
منهم او نتردد
وتزامنا او تجاوبا مع دعوه الرئيس امر
وزير الدفاع الكوري الجنوبي بتدشيني وحده
شامله للطائرات المسيره تقوم بهم متعدده
بما يشمل المراقبه والاستطلاع والحرب
الالكترونيه وانشاء منظومه لانتاج كميات
كبيره من الطائرات المسيره الصغيره التي
يصعب اكتشافها خلال العام الحالي الاتجاه
نحو التسليح وخلق منظومات جديده لم تلتفت
اليه فقط بل الجار اليابان ايضا التي زادت
بشكل ما هو الميزانيتها الدفاعيه لمواجهه
ما اسمته تحديا استراتيجيا غير مسبوق من
قبل الصين
[موسيقى]
تتابعون معنا في العربيه 360 ايضا
الحكومه الفرنسيه
ويتهمونها بعدم الوفاء بالوعود البيئيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قالت منظمه الصحه
العالميه ان بيانات هيئه الصحه الصينيه
اكادت عدم اكتشاف السلالات الجديده
من جهتها شددت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
انا الان بير بوك على ضروره التنسيق
المشترك مع منظمه الصحه العالميه بشان
مواجهه اوروبا لموجه كورونا القادمه من
الصين
هدفنا ايجاد حل مشترك ويجب ان نتعامل مع
هذه الموجه القادمه من الصين بجديه فارغه
ولن نتحدث عن تعاون الاوروبي فقط بلد
تعاون مع منظمه الصحه العالميه ايضا من
اجل الشفافيه الكامله حول الوظائف الصين
اوكيشن
360 من نيويورك لنجمين متخفيين هناك نتحدث
عن نجمي فريق باريس سان جيرمان الفرنسي
كيليان مبابي والمغربي اشرف حكيمي شهد
النجمان بالقرب من ميدان تايم سكوير في
نيويورك اثناء حضور حفل وهم يحاولا تخفي
لمنع اي شخص من التعرف عليهما حكيمي في
الزي الاخضر ارتدى كمامه وغطى راسه اما
بعد ما هو اشبه بقناع ابيض لتظهر عيناه
منه فقط ورغم ذلك تم التعرف عليه
واضحين تصريح اليوم من العربيه 360 هو
لرئيس استونيا الار كاريس بشان اللغه
الروسيه يقول كان سن الازمه الاوكرانيه
ليست سببا لمحاربه اللغه والادب الروسيين
وذلك تعليقا على دعوات بتهميش اللغه
الروسيه في البلاد يقول رئيس استونيا التي
كانت ضمن الاتحاد السوفيتي يوما ان اللغه
اداه والروسيه لغه الثقافه ويجب تعلمها
قبل لغات الاخرى يذكر ان اللغه الروسيه
يتم تدريسها في استونيا كاللغه ثانيه
فيديو اليوم من العربيه 360 من العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس الاثنين من نشطاء المناخ
الذين
رشاه المدخل الامامي لمكتب رئيسه الحكومه
بلون برتقالي احتجاجا على ما وصفاه بجرائم
المناخ التي ترتكبها الدوله واعتقلت
الشرطه الشخصيه على الفور وكنا يرتديان
قمصان او قميصين كتب عليهما من المذنب
واصدرت الحركه التي ينتمي اليها الناشطان
بيانا اكدت فيه ان فرنسا اخفقت في الوفاء
بالتزاماتها للمساعده في مكافحه تغيري
المناخ
طيب نحن اااه نختم العربيه 360 ولكن نشير
الى الاخبار العاجله عن بايدن يقول انه
قلق من تعامل الصين مع كورونا وناقش منح
اوكرانيا مركبات برادلي القتاليه فيما
الاتحاد الاوروبي قال ان الاتفاق على
تقديم القادمين من الصين لنتيجه اختبار
سلبيه لكرونا اذا تم الاتفاق على ذلك
وتصريحات خرجت من السويد
رئيسه الاتحاد الاتفاق على تقديم القادمين
من الصين نتيجه اختبار سلبيا لكرونا كان
الموضوع يعني مشتتا بين الدول كلهم بقرار